les images font froid dans le dos le
barrage de carrovecka l'un des plus
grands d'Ukraine
éventrés qui laissent désormais
s’échapper librement les torts du fleuve
bien propre 18 km3 accumulé dans le
réservoir menace directement des
dizaines de localités situés en aval une
course contre la montre s'est engagée
pour évacuer leurs habitants 17000
personnes côté Ukrainiens au moins 25000
sur l'autre rive
occupé par les forceus mais les services
d'urgence sont débordés alors les
habitants doivent se débrouiller par
eux-mêmes pour fuir leur maison avant
qu'il ne soit trop tard
Oxanna et sa famille ont été pris par
surprise elle explique avoir de l'eau
jusqu'à la taille chez elle et elle a
tout perdu
les meubles le frigo la nourriture
dit-elle je ne sais pas quoi faire alors
que l'armée ukrainienne prépare une
grande offensive contre force russe les
deux parties s'accusent mutuellement
d'avoir détruit le barrage mon arbre il
a été miné détruit par les soldats
russes qui l'occupent depuis un an
affirme le président zellinski qui parle
d'un désastre environnemental d'un acte
terroriste
un acte terroriste en effet selon le
ministre russe la défense qu'il attribue
cependant au fort ukrainiennes il faut
dire que ce barrage est une cible depuis
longtemps déjà touché par des explosions
en novembre alors que les forces russes
se retiraient de la région de rerson
selon cette analyse il est clair que le
crime profite surtout aux Russes les
Russes ont commencé à comprendre que ils
avaient déjà
à l'année n'est pas fini
cher en vie humaine des deux côtés
particulièrement du côté russe ils ont
donc pris la décision de faire détonner
le barrage de novatacovska un
développement inquiétant dans cette
guerre qui suscite beaucoup de réactions
et c'est un autre exemple de des
conséquences horribles de l'attaque
illégal de la Russie sur l'Ukraine
qui donne une nouvelle dimension à cette
guerre selon le chancelier allemand et
qui s'inscrit dans la lignée des
nombreux crimes commis par les soldats
russes seulagement la centrale nucléaire
de saporygia situé en amont n'est pas
touché et ne serait pas en danger
immédiat ici Jean-François Bélanger
Radio-Canada Montréal